Here is your next challenge.
In this rock, paper, scissors app,
the user selects from three buttons.
Then a view is presented with a response
from their opponent, the phone,
and a win or lose message.
Your challenge is to present the results
of a match in three different ways,
a different way for
each of the three buttons.
Implement presentation of the results
view controller from the rock button,
programmatically.
Implement the paper button using
a combination of code and segue.
And implement the scissors
button using only storyboard,
apart from the prepare for
segue method, of course.
When you're finished,
indicate your preferred method and
explain your choice in the text box.